hello I'm David seldom i er I'm a
retired professor of computer science
from the University of Hawaii and I'm
going to talk about the downloadable ask
constants program for Mathematica and
what it can do is it instead of taking
exact formulas like PI plus square root
of two and concluding I am computing a
floating point number can go the other
way sort of magically can unscramble an
egg and find out for you an exact
formula that corresponds to your float
sometimes
I got intrigued the first time I saw
this program that you would give it a
floating point number that you'd perhaps
computed by integration or find root or
something where you couldn't find an
analytical answer and you defeated in
that floating point number and it would
feed you back some candidates forum
constant expressions like PI over 2 plus
the square root of three that were
candidates for what what that float
would approach the limit of that float
as you increase your working precision
and I would just fit I was spitting by
it I said that's just a magic and so I
brought along a magic hat and it's like
it's like unscrambling an end you know
there's a there's a broken egg okay and
put it in there and then let me hold
abracadabra because holy yeah yeah
resurrected and so wow that's magical
and so I wanted to do a program like
that maybe because i need a wolfram
alpha alpha actually does this but I
needed a function yeah i know the
culprits right there I needed a function
because I was going to use in another
program I want to call it and use the
results so I wrote my own and here it is
i'm going to show you an example you can
just what you here's where you type your
float in but i'm not a really good
typist uh in awkward positions like this
i'm just going to click on there's some
canned examples that are in that are in
here and it's actually a good idea to do
them anyway so you get an idea what the
program does when you first use it so
there's a flow press the Go button this
particular folia there's one candidate
that it has okay this particular float
was a four dimensional quadrature that
no our computer algebra system could do
symbolically and one of the pioneers in
this whole area David Bailey
use it and found this expression using
one of these other programs and so this
program does it too and what's this over
here well this is a plot of that point
that one expressions is showing their it
plots this entropy is a measure of
complexity okay you think of leaf count
plus leaf count plus bite counts
somewhere in between okay it's actually
the entropy of a number is a base to
logarithm of its absolute value of an
answer and nonzero integer and so I just
take those and add those all up for for
all the integers that are in there
cluding the numerators and denominators
and then I add about one for every
operator or symbolic constant like pie
and add that all together except i use
based in logs because i want to compare
that complexity measure directly against
the agreement the number of digits the
degree between the float and this
proposal for what explains the float so
these are the same units on the two axes
and what i found is that this method I'm
using tends to have a lot of bogus ones
you can go in and it just bogus a lot of
them have huge coefficients which is a
sign of over fit okay I have a models
have a bunch of models in there and I'd
you essentially try to fit unknown
coefficients for them and these are
Lonnie's are both these are all bogus I
found out the bogus ones tend to line up
along the lower left corner of the of
the plot region and that suggested that
a good and then the good ones were
tended to be up more towards the upper
left corner and that's so that the
difference in those two agreement minus
entropy dient the agreement margin was a
good discrimination function and it
converted a dual objective optimization
problem where you want you want high
agreement but you want low complexity
and so this creates a dual objective
problem into a single objective problem
and it really tends to discover you see
it visually like this the function is
fine and you can use it but when you see
I don't want to actually return all
these rejects because it just you look
at it sat whoa what's what and you takes
you a long time to figure out what is
the one you want but here on the plot
it's very clear which one is the winner
here okay now how do I that's this is
not a proof it's just this is a
conjecture generator that's what it is
and if you're not given to prove what
you can do is simply recompute it the
expression if I once I have this well we
compute the float the quadrature the
four dimensional quadrature to higher
and higher precision if if the agreement
just keeps climbing and climbing and
climbing I up you know as far as you go
that's a pretty good sign that your
conjecture is actually true if it stops
at a point and just sits there that's it
the bogus is revealed here's another
example this is one in this case instead
of putting the floating i put the
numerical function that generates it
this is float at any beginning calculus
student can it's just the integral of 1
over X and the upper limit is a
quadratic number and the lower limit the
log is 0 there so let's press go on this
the reason for the quotes if I love the
quotes off when I went it evaluated it
would replace my input with the floating
point number and then I would lose this
information that I wanted to continue so
I'm making a string and then to
expression from string and then that's
evaluated this time it found quite a few
answers okay and our original input is
right and what you would get in a
beginning calculus course I think most
students most of you would get most of
the students would return the log answer
but there's actually three others that
it found that have the same they're the
same value their equivalent but they had
lower entropy so this is sorted by
diminishing entropy and then there were
three more of five more that had higher
entropy so it find them on how did it
know they were equivalent well it used
possible 0q function the mathematica
possible 0q function
on the differences between the two and
so it established beyond a reasonable
doubt that these were equivalent and the
value of hooking them together here is
if I didn't hook them together and
didn't check to see if they're
equivalent then the user who wants them
to find a proof he has seven different
things he could try to prove this he
only has to prove one of these in and
he's proven he's proven them all and and
you can't say which one's best it depend
him on what the purpose is you know he
really might water in our tangent a
hyperbolic arctangent or a log or
something like that you can choose the
functions there's a set of basic
functions you can choose the functions
that are in the basis for this search at
least 41 it says really to there's two
algorithms in the search and the first
one is a big lookup table and it's fixed
it takes a lot of work for me to
generate that table and it's fixed so if
you get the answer from that table even
if you don't choose a function if it's
if you know if you use all these
functions you haven't selected here's
another here's another one factorial
family for example if you choose one you
know you can get an answer that isn't
actually checked off but if it's in the
second phase of the search that's an
estimate some more time consuming part
you have to have that function checked
in order for it to to find it now you
see someone but you'll see some
functions here that aren't built in
Mathematica functions real inverse that
real in vs well this the method that I
use the second method requires inverse
functions for every function you want to
recognize you have to have an inverse
and for multi-branch function you have
to have all the branches covered and
very few the special functions have
inverses air for does have a sign does
maybe one or two others the reason is is
that mathematica special functions work
over the complex domain usually for if
it's two parameters like Bessel function
both of them completely over the whole
complex plane that is a very
hard job to get an inverse that's going
to work for all of that but I'm only
interested in reels and so it wasn't all
that hard to write real inverse
functions for about 50 special functions
in Mathematica and so you'll notice that
for example for gamma real inverse gamma
is actually checked already I think it's
a very common relatively common choice
and it doesn't cost me that much so
let's do the next example here upstarts
the same example I've meant to do five
and there's an example where were real
inverse gamma came in because the fine
root up here I'm essentially inverting
this this this equation up there and
another example is this is an integral
at that mathematica can do symbolically
but it but illustrated something really
nicely so I chose it anyway and that
that way I know it's the right answer
this particular one involves a constant
glacier now I didn't know what that I
thought that was a rice field something
like that but I didn't know what it was
but you can also choose named constants
and basic ones are you know the ones
even as a fat as a matter of fact is
when I was a calculus student I think I
knew about pie and a whaler gamma but
these other three I'd never heard about
so but there's a lot of interesting ones
for example function approximation
enumeration function iteration some of
the names are actually quite interesting
like the oldest akasa name ubiquitous
who's ever seen it but it's your name
ubiquitous so it's kind of fun just to
try to run down this guy I think I've
met this guy some more taut and so you
can choose some constants I have a
Stephen Finch road award-winning book on
mathematical constants and I took about
one hundred forty of them how many
constants 109 of them so far that I put
in there but you can choose them and
that's where this glacier constant came
from okay
and another dice choice is a it's just
try a random one okay and this is a
random 16 digit float and all i get is
rejects and that's that is the way it
almost always is you rarely get anything
that's rated more than bad bad is a
merit that's smart domoj in the
agreement minus the entropy pin and you
really get a random flow to get even up
in this bar Murdoch I think once I've
seen it up in the poor okay and that's
because the reels are uncountable but
but the set of all formulas you can
write is countable what it would you
know find it up number of them it's kind
of wealth countable period and so the
the reels are the formula the ones that
have a formula is that you can attribute
them to correctly is as a set of measure
0 well it isn't the set of measures here
because I'm only using 16 digit folks
here but so but but but in fact 16 is
enough so that you just simply almost
always get things on it hears you notice
they sort of clumping to that that first
phase table lookup tends to give things
down here with with modest coefficients
they're like two digits and so on these
are all you know these ones look like
they could be plausible it's hard for me
to write to keep that mouse on there but
yeah okay so you know but thing is
agreements very low in this case these
ones up here are done by find integer
integer null vector it essentially does
a linear least squares fit to a single
data point we just heard of statistics
talk and no citations would laugh at you
if you if your data set side was one but
the difference is the coefficients the
unknown coefficients have to be integer
say and that that that's enough
determination to give you something so I
noticed and in fact this is this example
like with the inverse hyperbolic some of
those answers were better than the
answer than the usual answer of log log
of a quadratic number and that's the one
that almost every calculus book would
list because
us they study hyperbolic sine inverse
hyperbolic way at the end of the course
if they have time and so that the
students never learn those but i notice
that often but when i took examples out
of integral tables and tables of
infinite series closed forums i notice
it fairly often the answer was simpler
than the one in the table or the one in
the calculus book and so that gave me
the idea to make a simplification
function based on that it's kind of like
a backdoor quantum tunneling or
something you you have a you start with
an action this is for this one you
actually start with an actual formula
like here's double factorial example
that's an orb horrible-looking
expression very ugly okay then you do
value you figure out how many you can
measure the entropy of this input
because it's a non float so you measure
the interview you compute the entropy of
it and you add on a certain amount like
10 more and you say that's the precision
i'm going to use and if it's modeled if
it's in fact me what this could simplify
to or this itself was modeled then it's
very highly likely that i'll come up
with that okay so it's a kind of funny
tunneling you go to the float even you
go to the float but you come back with a
non flow dancer which may but here let's
do this beautiful 31 / 29 double
factorial big simplification the input
had entropy about 30 and this one has
about five so it's a big reduction okay
and here's another example oh how do I
know that's right I mean maybe okay you
came back well I used here I gather
again I have two non floats so i use
possible 0q on the difference between
them and it goes up to like a hundred
digits or so and if it's still fine it
says well I'm not sure but we'll say
true that's the way it works here's
another interesting example
on this horrible nested radical I say go
it actually could be boiled down to a
single sinusoid of a rational multiple
PI I mean there's a everyone teeps wants
to go the other way I think it's a kind
of this compulsion you know get rid of
the signs and make radicals but here
it's pretty clear that the sign is a
certainly more concise representation
interpret n five point five verses 20
here's another example beyond Galois
there's a root expression and there is a
function in Mathematica called two
radicals well by a very name it wouldn't
allow you to return this one but I found
you can also have it I mean there are
other there are other kinds of clothes
forms for root besides radicals and
trigonometric functions are one
trigonometric functions of rational
compositions of trigonometric functions
of rational multiples of Pi or algebraic
numbers so this goes in the other
direction and it does it either pot
there may be an algorithm for going
directly from from here to here I don't
know I haven't really explored it but
this does it by doing figuring out a
float that has a precision about 10 more
than the than the entropy of this
Express that they give an expression and
then evaluating it to a float and then
taking that float and trying to fit it
using this producing the proposed
function and then at the end using
possible 0q to decide if it's equivalent
in this case I could actually decide for
sure by using a root reduce ok but its
root reduce there's two methods and
sometimes one is pretty fast the other
slow and I you know it slowed that down
too long so I much but I chose not to do
that
can you get that's exactly right and
that is a something I'm going to work on
I i didn't i didn't use the cancel
function in mathematica seemed to me
like it always happens just that's
exactly what it is i want to i want to
multiply it by minus 1 if that will
reduce the number of minus signs and i'm
just going to write my own function cuz
i don't want to hit it with simplify and
maybe it will look all over the world
for all kinds of things and I just
wanted a quick simplifying I discovered
there is a quick simplifying Mathematica
undocumented but it's in there somewhere
okay let's talk about that that's a
thought okay so let me just sort of tell
you a little bit about this thing it's
freely downloadable from ask Constance
org okay and it actually includes some
packages with which actually many people
might find more valuable than this it
includes a zero is package which is like
the vessel vessels j 0 and vessel y0
area i 0 does a for others for them in
mathematica 10 i haven't looked at
eleven this has about 20 more that i
wrote up and then there's an fee mensa
premium packages was analogous except
that it finds the the poles and zeros
and stuff and it gives the abscissas in
the ordinance of the experiment suprema
of about forty functions and then is
about 40 real inverse functions that
have been implemented to that might be
more useful to some of you than this ass
Constance program and and also the
proposed function like I said it's a
function available separately and so is
then simplify well thank you very much
it was
you
[Applause]